hi it's ria today i've been challenged
to take a popular food and make it fancy
today's challenger is alex hey rie it's
your best friend in the entire world
alex so today i'm gonna challenge you to
make one of my favorite candies in the
world fancy m ms last time i challenged
you to make skittles fancy and you did
an amazing job i figured that m ms are
like the chocolate equivalent of
skittles i can't wait to see you i can't
wait to see what you make me and
remember
to make it fancy
eminems of course i've had it before i
feel like it's a little bit too sweet
for me good thing it's day a little so
you can stop when you feel overwhelmed
i'm gonna have a quick sample since i
haven't tried this for a long time
i like the crunch first few bites are
great if your hands become rainbow
somehow i like brown one the best i want
to make something i've never made in
this show before i got some great idea
and as always i'm excited to make it
fuzzy
all right here's what i got strawberries
apricots vanilla cookies heavy cream
butter yogurt avocado almonds goat
cheese cherries and milk from the pantry
i got flaxseed cocoa powder maple syrup
sweetened condensed milk baking soda
brown sugar dark chocolate white
chocolate taco nibs pistachio coconut
oil flour salt powdered sugar and brandy
okay let's get started
make it fancy
first combine dry ingredients i have one
cup of flour 1 4 cup of brown sugar 1
teaspoon of baking soda half teaspoon of
salt mix
well with whisk
and i have one cup of whole milk quarter
cup of yogurt mix well one tablespoon of
flax seed one tablespoon of cacao mix
quarter cup of pistachio half cup of
dried cherry since m m's had so many
varieties i'm going to use peanut m m's
for this adding one cup and i'm using
more different kinds of m m's later
which do you think was invented first
the chocolate m m or the peanut m i
think chocolate right
yes do you know the year
nineteen
1941 it seems like a lot of
all the good stuff
i was gonna say junk
it's invented in 1940s yeah of junk food
pour this butter in a loaf pan bake this
at 350 degrees for 50 minutes cool down
to room temperature and freeze it for a
bit so we baked and cold and put in the
freezer the reason we put in the freezer
it is easier to cut thinly there's a lot
of hard ingredients like nuts and dry
fruits in it so it's a little tough to
cut if you have a sharp knife or a bread
knife it will do well so lay them on the
tray this is not like other pastry it's
not like cookies or cream puffs so it
doesn't expand so you can actually put
pretty close each other i'm going to
finish cutting them back at 300 degrees
for 15 to 20 minutes until it dries out
one cup of heavy cream so this time i'm
using mini m m's because it will melt
quickly half cup cook until everything
melts m m's are the most common eating
chocolate in space it kind of makes
sense right because it's
everybody loves chocolate i'm not
interested going to space so the only
thing you will see is like those planets
there is not many things you can eat
we are living in such a beautiful planet
and we have so many choice you can eat
whatever you want to eat but if you are
going to space you have to wear
same thing and
food is limited and
there is so many things i haven't seen
in this world and why go to
space everything is melted in
heavy cream put this m m and heavy cream
mixture into a blender this is smell
like a nice hot chocolate i'm adding one
avocado quarter cup of maple syrup two
tablespoons of cocoa powder one pinch of
salt i'm going to blend this
pour
coat this to room temperature and chill
in the refrigerator at least 30 minutes
1 cup of heavy cream in a small pot 10
on dark chocolate and now i'm using the
regular m m's adding six zones two
tablespoons of butter
mix it up do you know what their slogan
is
melting pot of chocolate milk chocolate
that melts in your mouth and not in your
hands
it melts in your hand m m doesn't need
to be melt completely for this one take
off from the heat transfer this into a
bowl add three quarter cup of pistachio
3 4 cup of almond three quarter cup of
crushed vanilla cookie 2 tablespoon of
brownie using spatula and mix everything
well combined put this in a refrigerator
about 30 minutes or until moldable the
chocolate mixture foamed up so i'm going
to divide this in half put in a plastic
wrap and shape it into a log twist the
corner
and you kind of hold this and tie
the corner
press against on the flat surface and
make even a thickness look gonna do one
more put the mixture in plastic wrap
cover with plastic tie the corner and
press against flat surface and make an
even
thickness lock chill this until
completely firm about one to two hours
okay so the chocolate log is completely
firm spread powdered sugar in the sheet
pan and unwrap
and cover with powdered sugar brush of
excess with pastry brush and i'm going
to slice it has a lot of hard
ingredients like cookies and pistachios
so instead of slicing like a slow motion
you kind of press it and
push it down like guilty is this how
grote work
probably
just use the heel of your knife and just
use the gravity i'm going to finish
cutting this and we have plenty more
things to do i have a double boiler
adding
one and a half cup of white chocolate
seven on seeds of sweet condensed milk
and two tablespoons of butter mix it
until everything is completely melt and
i'm using double boiler because white
chocolate is easy to burn and also
butter helps white chocolate not get
burnt so i have a glazed container and
i'm going to transfer this
nice texture chill this in the
refrigerator about three hours or until
it's become completely firm one cup m
m's are in a food processor
[Laughter]
we didn't expect it was coming out from
here okay
this
looks good add in the meshi and strain
and i just want to use this dust so i'm
going to put bigger bits in a separate
bowl so this is the chilled fudge i just
made earlier sprinkle this dust over the
fudge and you want to coat this evenly
i am not a cheese i'm a cheese lover my
instagram account it's the dessert snow
but i'm not am i snob
maybe put this in a refrigerator until
i'm going to use it we still have so
many things left double boiler going i'm
adding six ounces white chocolate and
one tablespoon of butter while it's
melting i'm going to combine six on six
goat sheets quarter cup of powdered
sugar and 2 tablespoons of milk my white
chocolate mix is nice and melted put
this over to my gold cheese mixture
put half cup of mini m m's and half cup
of chopped apricots fold them into
white chocolate mixture so we are going
to put this in the refrigerator about 30
minutes until moldable my white
chocolate mixture is the texture i want
it and i'm going to use
plastic
the texture you want it's fine but not
too fun you can mold it as you want so
the texture you're looking for is mashed
potato i was thinking about
we were stretching on the break
in japan
during summer break i don't know if the
kids still do it
we have to go to
like a park and do the exercise every
day at 8 or 7 am and if you go there you
get the stump and you have to turn to
teacher after the summer vacation do you
remember what the exercises are yeah
like i still remember
there's
a lot of like this
and jumping
while i was exercising i shaped it into
a
rectangle i'm going to put this in a
refrigerator about two hours until farm
meanwhile all of our
crews is going to do exercise for two
hours one cup of dark chocolate and one
cup of mini m m's crushed and two
tablespoons of coconut oil melt this
completely alex finally met my son she
was super excited he is confused
but she is great with kids i was a
little bit worried that shell is gonna
remain big but it actually melted quite
nicely so i'm not gonna use blender i
was going to change the plants take off
from the heat dip
this strawberry
so this needs you know classic chocolate
dipped strawberries but it has eminem's
shell in it so it's going to have a nice
crunch to it it might be a nice surprise
when alex try it i added coconut oil
into this chocolate mixture because it
will hardened much quicker than just
using chocolate and it is much easier
than tempering chocolate put this in a
refrigerator until chocolate hardened
and we are going to make something very
exciting i'm going to start with
chocolate salami kind of make it look
like a river and i want to make it look
a little natural so i want to show the
inside so i'm going to just cut the nice
red sheets it's just look like cheese
it's crazy
and you look like a pokemon i think
shakuta reborn is getting very popular
because yeah who doesn't like a good
shakutari boat and it's so
fun like there is a lot of things to eat
i'm thinking about color and shape but
mostly i'm kind of doing freestyle most
important thing is you want to make the
board full and also you want to put odd
number not even number so i'm adding
three pieces of chocolate deep
strawberry with m m's and m m chocolate
dip pop grapes
i like cut up fig because it's pretty
just put here and there
some
orange
chocolate is kind of dark and brown so i
kind of want to add some like pop orange
and other fruits peanut eminem i think
i'm gonna just fill space with this guy
just having fun i think this is perfect
for halloween for adults like grown-up
snacks so i have these cookies i'm gonna
put here apricots oh this is fun board i
want to come to this party i'm inviting
myself
finish with pretty edible flowers
and we are done
[Music]
eminem shakutari ball very fun and fancy
let's see what alex thinks
[Music]
oh my gosh is this a chocolate chocolate
reborn yes
chocolate salami oh my god what is this
like a debris
you always know how to do
a plus presentation oh thank you i want
to try one of these okay and one of
these i want to try to feel like cutting
you look like you're cutting cheese you
got the cheese hey cheers let me cheers
oh yeah wow it's unique it's a little
tangy delicious i would have never
paired goat cheese and nuts together
what is this oh chocolate strawberry i
didn't even realize oh should we eat it
like this like corn love
charcuterie
cheeseboard
charcuterie charcuterie
made me a chocolate charcuterie
and i say yay cause it was really
amazing
and dancing
[Music]
you